Speaker 1: Donald Trump has sued Hillary Clinton
in a very strange, sprawling lawsuit that doesn't
make any sense. Reuters is reporting Trump sues
Hillary over 2016 Russian collusion allegations.
Donald Trump on Thursday sued his rival in the
2016 election Hillary Clinton and several other
Democrats, alleging they tried to rig that
election by tying his campaign to Russia.
Now what's funny about this is this
is all crazy, and we'll go through it.
The Russia stuff. Really was after Trump had
won. So how could you rig and again, it's like,
do you not understand time? How do you rig the
2016 election by talking about Russia in 2017?
Doesn't really make sense. Anyway, the
lawsuit covers a long list of grievances
and comes as Trump continues to falsely claim
he actually won in 2020 acting and this is from
the lawsuit acting in concert. The defendants
maliciously conspired to weave a false narrative
that their Republican opponent, Trump, was
colluding with a hostile foreign sovereignty.
The lawsuit alleges racketeering and a
conspiracy to commit injurious falsehood.
A Clinton representative didn't respond. The
lawsuit wants compensatory and punitive damages.
Trump said he was quote forced to incur expenses
and an amount to be determined at trial, but known
to be in excess of $24 million and continuing to
accrue in the form of defense costs, legal fees
and related expenses. Do you accrue legal fees if
you don't pay them? I guess, sort of. But Trump
often doesn't pay his his lawyers. Another article
about this Donald Trump sues Hillary Clinton and
allies over Russia claims sprawling lawsuit
accuses a large cast of racketeering conspiracy
over allegations that Trump was in Putin's pocket
in 2016. So listen, as usual, you know how we've
talked about this unfortunate reality or
phenomenon where the right says, Hey, the
left is doing this and it's actually they who are
doing it. The left is going to rig the election.
Actually, you tried to, but fortunately you
failed. The left can't be trusted with classified
and secret and sensitive information. Actually,
it was you flushing documents down the toilet,
taking them to Mar a Lago, spilling secrets to a
Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office and on
and on and on. And likewise, here the right loves
to say the left is constantly suing everybody,
frivolous lawsuits. We've got to deal
with it, tort reform and all this stuff.
Isn't it time for a judge to start holding the
lawyers accountable who file these trash lawsuits
because they are absurd? And you can be sure I
mean, put take a step back. Everything else aside,
you can be sure this lawsuit won't go anywhere
because if it did, the defendants would have the
ability to carry out discovery and discovery could
include up to and including deposing Donald Trump.
OK, maybe Trump can raise money off of this in
the short term from his low information followers.
Maybe he can convince them like he can
win. So many of them donate to me and I'll
fund recounts and will flip this election, and it
was a lie. And many of them gave him money. Maybe
Trump can similarly tell them, give me money so
that we can sue Hillary. But in the long term,
this is going nowhere because Trump and his
lawyers know it would be a disaster if they were
subjected to discovery. And that's basically it.
This will almost certainly be dropped soon, and it
is another one of these instances of do as I say,
not as I do. And whatever I do by definition is
right because I'm doing it and everybody else is
lying to you and I'm telling you the truth, except
I lie all the time. That's basically the bottom
line here. I expect this to go absolutely nowhere